كيف سيؤثر هذا العام على محفظتنا بعد عام
عنوانه التضخم تشير توقعات المؤسسات كبرى
الى ان هذا العام سيتجه في الاقتصاد
العالم الى الركود متاثرا بالصدمات العام
الماضي لكن خبراء من امثال جولدن سيكس لا
يشاركون تشاؤم بالكامل ويتوقعون ان يشهد
نموا بنسبه 5% عام 2023 بحيث يكون التحسن
في النصف الثاني من هذا العام هذا التفاؤل
يعكسه تقريره موقع الرواتب العالمي اذن
تقرير موقع الرواتب العالميه يقول ان 20
23 سيكون عاما مميزا لزياده الرواتب حيث
اجرى مسحا اشار الى ان متوسط الزياده
ستتراوح بين 5% بعين الحسود وسبعه في
المئه فكيف اذا نبدا عامل الجديد من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه والاسته الرواتب لانه
اكيد نصائح سريعه ههه
[موسيقى]
خمسه نصائح لخصتها صحيفه
اتخاذ قراراتك الماليه في السنه الجديده
يؤكد التقرير ان البدايه بتهيئه نفسك
نفسيا للوصول الى الاهداف وتقول اننا
ننجذب ونجذب ما نفكر فيه معظم الاوقات
التقرير يشير الى ان تحديد الهدف اسهل
بكثير اذا كان بامكانك وضع رؤيه اكبر
للصوره اي ان احنا نفسك وقتا لوضع خطه
مبنيه بشكل افضل على التدفق النقدي الشهري
والاستهلاك والنفقات المتراكمه وهناك
برامج جدوله تساعد على ذلك ايضا اعاده
التفكير في الميزانيه اي يجب ان تجد انظمه
توفير او السداد اكثر سهوله وكذلك ووضع حد
للسحب او الدفع اليومي على بطاقتك
هنيه ولابد من جدوله الديون خاصه عندما
تجدها ترتفع دون سداد شهري واخيرا الادخار
واجب حدد جزءا من الدخل كانه قسط شهري
والتزم به واتمنى لكم سنه ماليه مريحه
[موسيقى]
تنضم الى القاهره رانيا يعقوب الخبير
الاقتصاديه يسعد صباحك يا رانيا كل عام
وانت بالف خير وسعاده وراحه البال يا رب
طب رانيا هناك من يتوقع هذا العام
اقتصاديا عاما للركود متاثره بالصدامات
العام الماضي وهناك من يتوقعه عمل للنمو
ولزياده الرواتب على كل حال كيف كاشخاص
سيؤثر هذا العام الجديد بكل ما يحمله على
رواتبنا وعلى محفظتنا
صباح الخير واهلا بحضرتك في اول يوم من
هذا العام الجديد عام 2023 يا رب عام مليء
بالخير والبركه على الجميع
مما لا شك فيه ان الازمه في 2022 كانت
ازمه كبيره جدا وتعدي عيتها كبيره ومن
الصعب ان احنا نقول انها هتنتهي في الربع
الاول في النصف الاول ولكن اغلب الظن ان
هيتم اا زي ما بيقولوا كده تراجع تبعيات
الازمه دي خلال النصف الاول من هذا العام
باذن الله يمكن اغلب التوقعات بتميل ان
النصف الثاني من هذا العام هيحمل الكثير
من الاخبار الجيده هيحمل نوع من الانفراج
انخفاض معدلات التضخم ولكن مما لا شك فيه
ان الازمات اللي بيمر بها على مدار
العامين الماضيين سواء على ازمه كرونه الى
ازمه الحرب الروسيه والتضخم خليتنا نغير
تفكرنا كمستهلكين بصوره كبيره جدا طيب
الاهم على الاطلاق هو طيب خلينا على اهم
لانه انا بدنا نعرف احنا كافراد على صعيد
شخصي كيف انا بدي اجعل عام 20 23 عام اا
وفير لدي من المال الى جانب انه لازم يكون
في زياده في الراتب لانه زياده في الراتب
هي بتبدا في تحسين الامور ومن بعدها تاتي
الطرق والتبس اللي ستعطينا اياها كيف
رانيا اشرحي لنا
يجب البحث عن طرق جديده لزياده مواردنا
واصبح العميم الماضيين هم الانسب على
الاطلاق في فكره ان احنا نبتدي نطور نفسنا
كثير من الشباب والافراد والموظفين
والعاملين ابتدوا يزودوا موارد رزقهم
بمعنى ان احنا ابتدينا نشوف ناس ابتدات
تاخذ كورسات في مجالات مختلفه وابتدت ان
هي تلجا الى زياده دخلها فكره ترشيد
النفقات اصبحت هو هي العامل الاهم في هذه
الفتره همم اسلوب الحياه اختلف يمكن دعاه
الازمه كافيت 90 ابتدينا نلاحظ ان نمط
استهلاكنا ايضا اختلف وابتدينا نشوف انماط
مختلفه ابتدينا نلجا الى المشتريات على
الانترنت ابتدينا نشوف ما يسمى بالريفيهات
ولا يهتم بفكره ان احنا نبحث عن الجوده
مقابل القيمه الفتره القادمه ايضا هتحمل
عوامل مهمه جدا يجب ان يلتفت اليها
الافراد عشان يقدروا يزودوا دخلهم وهي
الاهم من وجهه نظري بجانب تطوير النفسيه
عدم الاعتماد على بطاقات الائتمان حاليا
في هذا العام يجب ان حضرتك تبتدي تضع
استهلاكك بما يعني بما يوفره دخلك فقط
لانه زي ما بنقول كده الخروج من الازمه
يحتاج اجراءات احترازيه وتدبير مختلف عن
الاوقات العاديه احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر
شكرا لك يا رانيا يعقوب الخبير الاقتصاديه
من القاهره